hey guys today is the day we finally got
the brand new venom trailer that
everybody was talking about from San
Diego comic-con and Wow
this trailer is ridiculous and it's long
and surprisingly enough it's not filled
with a lot of the same scenes that we've
seen before in the previous trailers
also we are about to start a brand new
round of giveaways so if you're new to
my channel be sure to subscribe so you
can stay up-to-date so there are a few
cool new scenes that I really want to
talk about and there are a few new
scenes that are important that I want to
talk about
I'm a debride I'm a reporter now I
always seem to find myself questioning
something the government may not be
working at I found something really bad
I have been taken
look around the world who do you see
a planet from the brink of collapse
human games are disposable like man and
symbiote combined this is a new race
your species the higher life-form
we cannot just hurt people
the Aberdeen
so many little time
that power it's not completely awful
you have no idea how much you're scaring
me right now
cooperate
and you just might survive guys you do
not want to do this trust me
oops
we'll always come at a cost
[Music]
oh I have a parasite yeah name is Chan
so in the beginning it starts off with
Eddie Brock talking and he says that he
has been taken he's obviously talking
about the symbiote but this kind of
shows the relationship that he has in
the very beginning he's more of a slave
the Venom symbiote is pretty much in
charge and calls the shots and I think
as the movie goes on we'll see Eddie
take-charge a little bit more then we
cut to a scene where you hear dr. Drake
talking he says that human beings are
disposable but man and symbiote are a
higher life-form and then we get a
glimpse of a symbiote actually taking
over somebody it latches on to this guy
brings him to the floor and you can even
see it coming out of his mouth and then
it cuts to a scene with Eddie Brock
where you can see that he's currently
bonding with the symbiote he then asked
the symbiote what do you want from me in
which case the Venom symbiote replies
you'll find out again just kind of
really showing that the symbiote is in
charge here not Eddie Brock then there's
this awesome scene where Eddie Brock
looks in the window of a car and he
actually sees the symbiote you can tell
that he actually hasn't seen it before
because when he looks at it he's shocked
he touches his face he looks and just
complete disarray kind of like oh my
gosh that's what I look like that's
what's taking over my body then we have
this awesome scene that was talked about
at San Diego comic-con we're finally
seeing right now the Venom symbiote says
look into my eyes and then separates
from Eddie Brock's body forming his own
beam and looks him in the eyes also
scaring the heck out of Eddie Brock at
the same time but this is something that
is done in the comics and is something
that we all really wanted to see so I'm
so glad that they're actually doing this
in the movie and this again it shows
that venom the symbiote is its own beam
and Eddie Brock is fighting for control
over it because right now throughout
this whole entire trailer it seems like
the Venom symbiote is just completely in
charge but there are some benefits to
that because in the next scene we can
see the Venom symbiote heal Eddie we can
see that Eddie clearly has a completely
broken leg in which the Venom symbiote
takes over and heal
for him going over the rest of his body
healing everything
not a bad perk so from San Diego
comic-con we heard that venom will stand
ten foot tall and will also get some
venom catchphrases and that's exactly
what we get in this next scene venom
stands up clearly at least ten foot tall
and says eyes lungs pancreas so many
snacks so little time so the next few
scenes are pretty important because we
hear Eddie Brock say that power it's not
completely awful you can tell that he's
starting to kind of bond with the Venom
symbiote in a different way he's
starting to like it I love this because
they have already said that there aren't
really any real heroes in this movie
which is perfect because Eddie Brock is
not a hero venom isn't a hero so we
don't want them to turn into these good
guys in the movie not to mention that in
the comics the reason that Eddie Brock
and the Venom symbiote actually bonds so
well together and the symbiote just
doesn't kill the human life form that it
takes over as its host is because they
both share a mutual hatred for
spider-man
now all rumors of Tom Hardy being in
this movie have been shut down but point
being venom and Eddie Brock are not good
guys they're not heroes and I'm glad
that this movie isn't going to portray
them that way next is a pretty
interesting scene they show a woman who
has been infected with a symbiote we
believe this person to be scream actress
Michelle Lee plays Donna Diego who in
the comics is scream and as they showed
this other symbiote you hear venom say
Eddie cooperate and you just might
survive I believe that he's talking
about the other symbiotes riot and
scream because the next scenes are
scream shooting spikes out of her back
killing people and then we see dr. Drake
and his symbiote riots hands turn into
these huge acts like blades and just
kill about 10 people so dr. Carlton
Drake / riot is clearly the main villain
in this movie scream is probably a side
villain
I want revenge on dr. Drake for turning
her into what she is or something else
along those lines but riot is clearly
the main villain and the next scene is
just awesome
we see venom and riot fighting and riot
is just ripping the face off of venom
and you can see Tom Hardy underneath and
quickly after you can see venom and riot
ripping each other apart and you can see
Eddie Brock and dr. Drake underneath and
it's just super cozy and then we have
this last scene which is dark because it
talks about venom eating his arms and
his legs off and then his face but it
also does add some humor to the movie
and it's been said that there is a fair
amount of humor so awesome but the
coolest thing is when the guy asks what
the hell are you and then we see half of
Venom's face peel back to where you see
half of Eddie Brock's face and half of
venom and together they both say we are
venom then venom puts his whole face
back on and from what I believe happens
he eats this guy's head off and then the
trailer ends with a little bit more
humor so this trailer just blew me away
there was so much action there was so
much detail we saw the other symbiotes
we saw a lot of riot including him
turning his hands into axes and killing
people and him fighting venom so this
was the trailer that was shown at San
Diego comic-con we got it just like they
said we would and it definitely lived up
to the hype what do you all think of
this brand new venom trailer what was
your favorite part was it venom staring
at Eddie Brock face to face was it venom
standing ten foot tall was it finally
seen riot on screen fight venom let me
know in the comments below if you
enjoyed the video give it a thumbs up
please and don't forget to subscribe to
my channel so you can stay up to date on
venom and as I mentioned we will be
doing another round of giveaways soon
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
you
[Music]